Now, say that I wanted to write my data to
a new CSV file that included my new height plus
weight column. Again, this is a simple one-line process using
Pandas. I can simply call the data frame objects to
CSV method, and provide as an argument the file name
of the file I wish to write to. In this
case, baseball data with weight height dot CSV. There are
a number of optional keyword arguments I could provide here beyond
the file name. For example, if I wanted to use
a separator besides a comma, if I wanted to specify
how to handle missing values, et cetera. You should check
out the panda's documentation if you'd like to learn more.